son père à la barre laisse paraître une
indifférence un détachement tels que
rémy craque et se met à pleurer pour la
première fois depuis le début de ce
procès rémi kukulinski montre sa
sensibilité ses failles il faut dire que
son père le frappait l'insultait
lorsqu'il était petit plus les proches
se succèdent à la barre
plus la cour réalise à quel point la vie
de rémi kukulinski a été chaotique
il n'a pas vu son fils depuis trois ans
ce fils et et des applis 60 kg c'est un
cetain s'éteint c'est un quasi de
légumes
il vient à la barre de cette cour il
reste stoïque quand il le regarde c'est
parce qu'on lui demande de le regarder
quand il le regarde cet hymne affectif
il n'y a pas d'amour dans ses yeux il le
regarde comme un étranger comme comme
une espèce de chose curieuse c'est
vertigineux set mais je ne juge pas cet
homme si vous laissez pas on n'est pas
là pour ça encore une fois on est là
pour comprendre ce matin c'est le
médecin légiste qui est d'abord
intervenu six personnes sont mortes par
intoxication une autre s'est défenestrée
pendant l' incendie
des détails qui ont été portées aux
oreilles des deux accusés la réalité des
faits les rattrape
ce sont désormais les familles de ses
victimes qui ont enfin la parole des
personnes qui ont besoin d'interprète
pour s'adresser aux jurés et pour
exprimer leur désarroi et leur douleur